on the streets of Gaza a human-sized
virus walks around raising awareness
about covert xix an effort to make
learning about the virus engaging and
accessible it's a challenge caregivers
around the world are facing as they try
to explain the battle against an
invisible enemy the pandemic is keeping
around a billion children away from
school it's really important to be
honest and tell the truth and sometimes
people say what how can I tell the truth
my child is so young and that's okay we
can tell the truth
using age-appropriate language watching
our children's reaction being sensitive
to the level of anxiety UNICEF has
helped publish a story called my hero as
you to help adults who may be struggling
to find their own words to explain why
the world has been turned upside down
use Eiland science educator dr. Michelle
Dickinson uses videos to tell kids
they're superheroes their mission to
destroy the virus by washing their hands
she says the activities help children
feel like they can control something
when everything normal has been put on
hold the fear is you know in trying to
shield your child from the world
actually learning some false information
from others and then maybe their anxiety
is gonna go up in these unprecedented
times many homes are now also workplaces
and schools and the hours spent cooped
up inside are putting extra pressure on
families kids really follow what we say
but they even more follow what we do and
how we act so we want to be aware of our
own emotions and manage those emotions
by modeling non-anxious coping which
sometimes means acting a little bit
calmer than we feel inside but it's so
important to to show our kids that we
can become and
in a time of stress we may not be like
this spider-man entertaining kids stuck
at home but the experts say we all have
superpowers up our sleeves to fight this
pandemic stay home be kind and use soap
because beating the coronavirus really
is in our hands
alexia Brian al-jazeera